[Music]
first stop
fifty miles north of Edinburgh it's
Bonnie son Andrews
this town is not only famous for his
golf venue but also Nam gym an amazing
Thai restaurant is run by a dynamic duo
husband and wife sandy and B and they
play themselves I'm cooking authentic
Thai cuisine today I'm expecting nothing
less than a hole in one I'm gonna see
anyone's cottage in the brigade no sorry
well husband sorry they only Scott in
the village
the first and only tyrant in st. Andrews
Nam gyms Charmin authentic cuisine has
taken the town by storm
determined to WoW the locals bees even
created and inspired signature dish
using Scotland's national fair haggis
very spicy it doesn't actually taste
like haggis to say buy pork doesn't it
that's delicious
what I love most about this place is
there Jeff from B she's burst with
energy she's happy in her cooking I
start happy and it shows in the food
amazingly but he had never cooked
professionally until she and her husband
sandy open-armed Jim eight years ago
successful businesses all in the detail
we kind of try and be the best we can be
we use the best ingredients from
Thailand great service we just won't do
everything as good as it could be the
way this has won the restaurant a huge
following of celebrity golf fans
this is my Hall of Fame that's a Tiger
Woods's mother mr. Sean Connery here mr.
Samuel Jackson he just said thank you
very much your food is wonderful I was
so proud now being Sandy's hard-fought
reputation is about to be tested to his
limits
my coach full of hungry diners are just
around the corner all 30 of them will
expect a faultless meal in just two
hours
[Music]
I'm gonna be over everything not just
the dining room but in the kitchen as
well and as you know I miss nothing
I'll be spotting everything manager
sandy is in charge of keeping all my 30
diners happy pain ease team must explain
Bea's unique Thai dishes one of the
house specialities is the Thais Scottish
haggis we also make that with a
vegetarian haggis which is essentially
pulses and nuts fee the orders are start
the roll now yeah yeah as well as the
haggis B's menu includes vegetarian
jungle curry and tamarind up with packed
joy as fast as front-of-house send the
orders through being her efficient type
of gate on knocking out amazing food
Thai cuisine
it's quick it's not along with his style
of cooking is done in a very fresh and
sort of rapid way sandy the only bread
on the team is the all-important link
between the dining room and the kitchen
are you at your weakest in here when
they're speaking through entire that's
just kind of ignore what they're talking
about like to see kind of what they're
doing more than
[Music]
it's not a race to me the standards far
more important okay if the starters are
anything to go by the standards don't
seem to be a problem absolutely